let's have a bit of a broader look at
the state of the pandemic right now and
talk about that with Dr Uber Janssen
since he's an intensive care doctor here
in Germany and the former president of
the German Association for intensive
Medicine Dr Jan says here in Germany one
of the country's leading virologists has
made Headlines by saying the pandemic is
over from your perspective as an
intensive care doctor do you agree
yeah the World Health Organization
announced the end of the global pandemic
back in September this year in this
respect I also agree with Christian
dross and Christian carginine is also an
intensive care medicine collect who also
predict the end of the pandemic in
Germany we will certainly still
experience one or the other small wave
of infections zaskov 2 does not
currently play the dominant role but
other respiratory pathogens above all
the influenza virus and RSV viruses in
the 50th week about 9 million people had
a new acute respiratory illness the
persistently very high numbers of
infections continue to exceed the peak
values that are usually reached in the
strong influenza waves the overall
proportion of patients hospitalized with
severe respiratory illness diagnosed
with influenza was 28 in the week 50 and
the portion of covid-19 was only 11
percent
um now how do you uh see covet affecting
our lives in the future
yes I'm I'm certainly sure that in the
future in the future we will have to
deal with saskov 2 and covid-19 but I'm
quite sure it will not reach the
proportion hospitalized on intensive
care medicine and other way we have to
to deal with that infection as we do we
have to deal with the influenza and we
have to live with this and we have to
encounter new viruses in the next
decades which may hit us as well as
zaskov II did talking about uh new
viruses right now China is battling a
wave of infections uh how big is the
risk of a new of new variants emerging
from there briefly if you can
so I think at the moment the huge number
of infection that is a risk that some
mutants developed it could be but that
is not true and leading virologists also
say it could be but that's not sure so
we should take any measure to protect us
self and people traveling to China
should uh wear mouth masks and they
should be vaccinated that's quite sure
at the moment I don't think we don't see
any urgents to for new variant of
concerns coming from China but that is a
threat I agree
intensive care doctor Uber jansens thank
you very much for your opinion
thank you
yes into the pandemic more than 650
million people around the world have
tested positive for covet 19. while the
vast majority recovers some are burdened
by long-lasting symptoms
the condition is called long covet the
symptoms differ from person to person
long covet is diagnosed if symptoms
persist for more than three months after
the infection while studies suggest
seven to ten percent of people who've
had covid-19 can be affected by
long-term symptoms of varying severity
the World Health Organization is calling
for more research into long covet as
well as better treatments for those
affected now our reporter Pippa Stevens
went to visit an interactive exhibition
here in Berlin where she experienced
what long covet actually feels like
[Music]
between 5 and 10 patients with the
coronavirus will go on to develop long
covid fatigue is one of the main
symptoms one paper estimates 46 percent
of people with the condition will suffer
exhaustion
I'm in front of one of the exhibits here
which is a weighted vest which together
with these weighted armbands and leg
bands weighs about 20 kilos now the idea
with this is to emulate the feeling that
people with long covid have of a very
sort of large pressure on the chest and
shortness of breath I heard one account
of a man who couldn't read his children
a bedtime story because he described
this sandbag on his chest
I try the leg and arm weights on along
with the suit to see what it's like
I try walking up the stairs
I already feel really quite out of
breath just walking up those stairs and
I'm conscious that my heart is beating
quite a lot harder than usual
um I feel quite sick to be honest as
well with the with the effort of the
weights and my body's also in a bit of
pain from sort of supporting the weights
people with long covert are advised to
keep moving to help with their
Rehabilitation the center uses virtual
reality to encourage that with
activities like football archery or
boxing
the hope is that by increasing their
strength long covered patients can get
back to their lives
what I've really taken from this
exhibition is not only how or consuming
and intense having long cover could be
but also how difficult it could be to
function in everyday life
now there are around 200 symptoms
associated with long covid so any
treatment would be highly individual in
how it was tailored still not very much
about it is known medically but the
center told me what it does do is point
people in the right direction of medical
care and also towards support groups
that can help them cope